we will have so much winning if I get  elected we're going to have win after  win after win that you may get bored  with winning we're going to win we're  going to win and we're going to win it  protects the Donald Trump will be the  winner  so excited that Donald Trump won I just  picked up that guy right there and I  hugged him Joe Joe Joe don't think we'll  make it an awesome president it feels  like we won the Super Bowl is a huge  victory in truck we stop bragging rights  now we are going to start winning again  and we're gonna win so much you're gonna  be so happy number one meet the next  president of the United States yeah  build the wall baby the biggest  landslide in the history of the United  States is Ronald Reagan I love you all  thank you very much thank you  thank you very much